what is happening there reject nation
happy monday if you saw my community
post you'll know i was out of town just
got back into town and of course
you gotta produce more youtube videos i
am wearing
my batman filipino pride shirt because
hitler and diaz just won
the first olympic gold medal for the
philippines
pride baby
possibly that's for dramatic positive
dramatic effect
we're going to watch in 3c films the
flash new footage reveals
ben affleck's batman on a bike
cool
bat bike
[Music]
barry allen whoa is that bruce wayne
what are you doing here man tell me
about this
oh yeah i was planning on buying that i
thought it'd make the flash cringey
intros even funny every wearing that
like i could be surrounded by hot dogs
or i could be
running away from a pregnant wife
because that's hilarious you know
running away and being an absent father
and whatnot and
oh my god
triggered by absent fathers 7k likes
okay i don't care who stabs me in the
eye hello flash fans thanks for watching
hit that like button people on his video
first looks at our other flash movie
that have been released online what i'm
going to be doing here for you guys is
showing you off some set
footage along with some set photos
involved with the flash movies
starring edgar miller michael keane and
ben affleck and well
speaking of ben affleck we have the boy
caught in 4k
income 4k bicycle that he's writing in
the movie
he's got to put some big smile on a lot
of fans faces right there we're going to
be diving
what do you think of these set photos
what do you make out of this set footage
do you like the fact that ben affleck
is actually gonna be suiting up in the
flash movie does this bring your
excitement up a little bit
for the new batman multiverse film i
mean the flash movie but on that note
what do you think of barry allen having
to share the spotlight with all these
heroes all right so yes this was the
first thing i saw when i woke up in the
morning and i really want to give my
hats off to this user account
at flash film news they've been really
good at staying up to date with the
update should i check my twitter this
board
stop checking the twitter able to find
all this stuff go ahead and give them a
follow if you want to stay up to date on
the flash news we were all getting these
little set photos of gotham city that
was being prepared for the flash movie
now
it's always confusing to know which
gotham city we're gonna be looking at
here because we're set to get
two gotham cities one that belongs to
ben affleck's batman and the other one
that'll belong to michael keaton's
batman
are we gonna see a version where michael
keaton
and ben affleck meet each other they
gotta meet each other i didn't even
think about that
i was thinking that he would just hop to
different universes or he runs into the
michael keaton one runs into the ben
affleck one but damn that would be
so exciting this batman multiverse film
is shaping up to be something awesome
this one obviously seemed like it would
be for ben affleck's batman because it
was more modern day
and that's usually what they're going
for with ben affleck's gotham city
so that meant if we were seeing ben
affleck's batman does that mean we're
about to see the boy out and about
wearing a suit talking to barry allen on
the streets because
we all know ben affleck is part of this
flash movie we just didn't know
to what capacity everyone's assumption
is that he's only in the movie for like
the first 10 to 15 minutes that way the
audience has an understanding for what
batman
looks like in barry's universe how his
mannerisms how he acts and
when barry goes into the multiverse and
meets michael keane batman
we get a whole different contrast and
barry's blown away like whoa
you're nothing like my batman because my
batman's dating j.lo
by the way i'm very happy for you i
think ben affleck watched the movie
hustlers and was like
i need that back
yes i think that's absolutely true
because we've been hearing that he's
only in the movie from the very
beginning
and it's also rumored to be his goodbye
to the character that whatever happens
in the flash movie that will kind of put
to wrest ben affleck's batman and we
won't really be seeing him
in the dcu he might still be out there
alive but he'll only be referenced in
the background and we won't actually see
ben affleck anymore because the man is
busy doing other stuff now but thank
goodness
it looks like the man is still going to
be suiting up in the flesh
this is absolutely amazing look at that
awesome
sequence with ben affleck's batman i
have always been a fan of good actors
batman
how it feels like he kind of got the
butt end of the sticks and twitter
brothers didn't really have a handle on
their dc universe so we only got to see
ben
pop up in other people's movies without
him having his own film to shine
so we got plenty of great batman action
sequences out of ben affleck i mean the
suicide squad scene with him in the
david ayer movie is still some of my
favorite stuff of ben affleck
so now to be able to add at least one
more awesome action
scene with by catholics puts a real big
smile on my face let's dissect though a
little further what we're seeing here so
obviously
he's wow wow cool
that we're going to be seeing two
different batmen on two different bat
cycles in the year 2022
don't forget this movie does come out
the same year as this film and we've
already looked up we're
grounded robert says he made it himself
that's year two batman give him a break
but this motorcycle definitely seems to
be fitting the design of his batmobile
if that does not read a big d energy i
don't know what it is it's
literally protruding from his crotch
look at that
one two though i mean you gotta look
down you see that you got this giant
wheel well on the front covering this
little tiny actual
tire so you know there's probably a
little compensation in there as well
that bike is so massive i can't get over
here
that is a thick boy it's like a
miniature tank
oh man i love it it feels like it just
has that same sort of build and i
wouldn't be surprised if it's kind of
like a christian bale thing where
once that batmobile gets destroyed he's
able to pop this out of that batmobile
or maybe he just used scrap parts and
built this himself as a quick side note
because i know there's going to be
someone screaming it in the comment
section
this isn't ben affleck in the costume
right now it
is a stunt double like i was mentioning
ben affleck right now is on vacation
with his honey so he'll probably be
showing up to set later in the week or
maybe sometime next week and they're
just doing a lot of the stunt work but
either way even if you have a stunt
double there that means we're gonna get
some shots of ben affleck
wearing this suit in the movie and that
is awesome as far as the suit goes
it does seem to be a brand new suit it's
not exactly like the ones that we've
been seeing
in either justice league zack snyder's
justice league or even batman vs
superman in some close-ups of the suit
you can see it's a little more padded up
whether that's for the stunt double
safety
of being on that there'll be a cape
now as far as exactly what he's chasing
it's kind of unknown at this moment we
did get a different angle of this video
and what ben affleck's batman is going
to be chasing and it looks like a
vehicle from the army that is running
away whether some bad guys got a hold of
this
if it's in related to the move
just a little random scene that'll be in
the beginning of the movie then i don't
know where barry allen is or miller
comes racing and he's like oh what's up
bruce you need some help i got you
i like that shot right there it's like
batman just who shows up he's like
never mind you know i i don't need him
he's he's all the way out there i'm not
gonna catch him now
my my bike can't fit through this i
should probably
fix these poles here is property damage
this flash movie just gets more and more
intriguing by the day like i'm still
caught up
and wondering how the hell are they
going to explain to barry allen's in
this movie because i don't know if you
guys were able to catch one of my
previous updates where we got to see
ezra miller and a person who's
also supposed to be ezra miller in the
flash movie having a conversation
talking to each other
i know there's been a lot of confusion
and people think that this is his stunt
double but no guys this is
not his stunt double because one stun
double would have to wear exactly what
the actor is wearing that day filming
also the camera is right behind them and
it's recording them filming a scene
where they're talking to each other and
then we've seen
other league set photos where this other
actor is wearing the exact same clothes
that ezra miller is wearing later in the
movie so that explanation alone is going
to be interesting to see how they
describe that why barry allen looks
exactly the same in michael keaton's
universe as opposed to his own universe
when ben affleck and michael keaton look
nothing alike and act nothing alike i
mean i don't think it's that far-fetched
i haven't read that much of the flash
but i've seen a lot of the flash show
and that flash is constantly meeting
other flashes
going into other multiverses said we
shouldn't be interacting with each other
yeah they are
yeah ezra miller interacted with grant
gustin on the crossover
so yeah i don't think he's that
far-fetched even if it is just another
version that looks like himself
that's part of the fun is that sometimes
they look different and sometimes they
look the same and sometimes they'll get
batman that look really close to affleck
and sometimes they won't the other last
thing i want to say is
men seem ben affleck having an action
scene like this it
really really makes me hope this isn't
the last time we see him okay you have
the multiverse you can have different
characters in different universes you
can still do
the michael keaton movies with like
bringing in batman beyond and then give
ben
affleck his own little side movie or
something because after seeing this i
just don't want the man to be
the rest but that is just everything
going on with the flash movie right now
this is just some really cool stuff i
wanted to bring your guys attention
because i thought it was awesome to look
at
probably brings up some hype and turns
around some people who are hoping for
the snyder verse to be restored at least
you get ben affleck in their suited up
fighting don't forget to leave me your
thoughts down below on the set footage
and set
photos also be sure to like and
subscribe for more great movie related
content
follow me on twitter at 3c films or on
tick tock 3c films but as always i'm
chris
take care take care buddy thanks for
putting that video together man another
great job
what if they were total dicks and they
decided to kill off
ben affleck oh we have this thing going
on in our culture
where we kill off legacy characters for
some reason
yeah it's a real popular thing that they
love to do now
knowing how wb is what if they did say
i could see come on can you guys not see
it i know i'm not saying do you
want it i'm saying d can you see a
virgin
wb who's been so anti-snyder and
ben affleck we don't really know where
ben affleck stands sometimes he seems
like he's down for it and sometimes he
seems like he wants to just quit
you can see a scenario where they're
like we gotta kill them off we got
rubber padded it's a couple guys
that was the door to the scatter version
yeah you could totally see it right
come on and i mean dramatically it would
certainly do something for
ezra miller's barry allen anyway in
terms of the emotion yeah sure give them
the benefit of the death i think it can
be such a stupid
i don't i don't want it to happen i
don't see any positivity
i don't either i think it will eclipse
the movie with batman
ire that much further than it already
has that's what i mean once you were
talking about like oh crap i think i
this might be where it's going we'll see
but guys subscribe to 3c films if you
haven't done so already you can
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like
button put away pride right john i am
filipino